[Music]
what is up everybody it's Santa Mac here
for anime uproar and as I mentioned in
our last boku no hero video I will be
making weekly update videos as season 3
continues and here we will be discussing
all the most important things from each
episode and beyond I want to make these
videos as interactive as possible so
each week I will be asking you a new
question on our Twitter and Instagram
and my favorite responses will be
featured in the video last time I asked
you guys to come up with your own unique
quirk in the world of boku no hero and I
got a ton of great responses and this
week I asked you to come up with your
own idea for a new villain in the world
of boku no hero if you want to
participate be sure to follow us at
anime uproar on Twitter and Instagram
and reply to the question thread with
your own response I will be reading some
of the responses at the end of each
video and of course if you enjoyed these
types of videos you want me to keep
making them weekly be sure to leave a
like to let me know and if you are new
to the channel don't forget to subscribe
and Detroit smash that notification
valve episode 41 or episode 3 of season
3 starts off with the students of
classes 1a and 1b training to develop
the power of their quirks even further
quirks seem to function just like
muscles so the more you use them the
more powerful they become as the
training continues we also meet the two
other members of the wild Pussycats hero
team ragdoll and tiger due to their
unique abilities and strong teamwork the
Pussycats are considered by the teachers
to be the perfect group of heroes to
help the students develop their quirks
and we can see that tiger is especially
strict he really wants to push all the
students to go beyond their limits to go
plus ultra as the training finishes for
today and everyone eats their dinner
Deku notices that coda mandalas nephew
is not eating so he follows him in order
to give him a plate of rice and curry
deku ends up following coda to his
secret hideout burn the two of them have
a very interesting exchange Koda
believes that both heroes and villains
are just obsessed with power with
getting stronger and showing off their
quirks and Koda thinks that all of this
is meaning
and just leads to unnecessary violence
and suffering as deku observes Kota
hates the entire superhero society
because it is so focused on quirks and
those with stronger quirks are usually
more successful because strength is
valued I find it interesting that there
is such a clear difference between
Coda's experience and deku deku was born
without a quirk so he grew up looking up
to and idolizing heroes with strong
quirks code on the other hand feels like
the hero society and its obsession with
quirks led to his parents deaths so it's
really a clash of very different ideas
and life experiences but of course we
know what kind of person Deku is so he
doesn't just want to let it go
dec who wants to show Kota that heroes
can be truly good and selfless people
and that it's not just about power for
them it's not just about getting
stronger or getting rich this reminds me
of the whole stained ark and how stained
hates certain heroes because they want
to become heroes for their own selfish
interests but he does respect other
heroes like all might and deku because
he believes that they are sincere
genuine heroes who just want to help
others as all of this is happening
behind the scenes we see the villains
plotting their attack and waiting for
the right time to strike as we learned
in the previous episode the legal
villain somehow found out about the
secret location of the training camp and
they dispatched a special group of elite
villains known as the Vanguard action
squad to deal with the students at the
end of the episode the villains finally
make their move using poisonous gas and
other tactics to attack the students and
teachers in various locations at the
same time and the really interesting
thing to me at this very end of the
episode is how Dobby who we know was
inspired by stain says that the villains
will take down the false brilliance of
the hero title which in some ways
reminds me of how coda is seeing the
hero society at this moment
beneath the facade beneath the surface
of the glamorous hero society lurks a
darker side a world in which many heroes
become heroes for the wrong reason and
the thirst for power and the obsession
with quirks leads to needless conflict
and suffering this makes us think
whether some
like Kota if he doesn't change his way
of thinking could grow up to become a
supporter of someone like stain and
dobby people who want to unmask the ugly
truth behind the hero society
all in all my big takeaway from this
episode is that it's going down we are
only on Episode three and things are
already about to reach a fever pitch
which again just shows us what a
brilliant season we have ahead of us let
me know what you guys thought about this
episode in the comments below and are
you hyped to see the epic battle between
the vanguard action squad villains and
the students and teachers by the way if
you want to know who all these new
villains are and you don't care about
manga spoilers you can check out my
video where I explain every new
character that is going to appear in
boku no hero season 3 link in the
description and now for your responses
on Twitter and Instagram to my MHA
questions of the week regarding my first
question from last time about creating
your own quirk in the world of boku no
hero
Ethan Rankin calls his quirk activation
the user can forcefully activate someone
else's quirk when they are within 5
metres of them and all I have to say to
this eaton is keep watching season 3 I
don't want to spoil anything for you but
keep watching crimson dream says quirk
adaptive defense allows the user to
adapt to any action taken against them
in order for this quirk to activate the
user has to be attacked first and the
weakness of this work is that the
ability only effects damage from outside
effects so punches acid and fire but the
user is weak against internal threats so
I'm thinking like psychic powers this
would be a really interesting quirk to
see in action in battle because I'm
guessing the stronger your opponent is
and the stronger their attacks are the
more effective this quirk will be now
for the second question where I asked
you to create your own villain in the
world of boku no hero and come up with
their own unique backstory and quirk my
own entry just to give you an example
was villain named knox Taku backstory
angry at the world for not recognizing
his comedic genius he retreats to the
internet and forms an evil organization
known as the fan base knox tacos quirk
is sarcasm overload where his enemies
are driven to the brink of madness by
endless
Casta quips and even though knox taku is
undoubtedly an evil villain he is still
a really good anime youtuber be sure to
check out his channel
laughing moose wants to see a quirk
called self magnet that is able to pull
metal towards the user and collect
around the body like a magnet
essentially creating an armor sword
shield and all that sort of stuff the
backstory of this villain is that he
sought help trying to master this
powerful quirks but was rejected by hero
schools I'm guessing because the quirk
was too unstable and now he wants to
prove to everyone who rejected him that
he should have been accepted by society
uncle no heart by the way great
reference to the Care Bears says that he
wants to see a villain whose name is
Akiko Yamazaki aka marionette the name
of the quirk is puppeteer and it allows
him to control anyone he touches for up
to 30 minutes by touching any of their
pressure points but if he tries to use
the quirk for more than 30 minutes he
will lose his memory and uncle no heart
even has a cool drawing for his villain
to go along with the entry creme Sankey
Borg 7 has an idea for a villain by the
name of Damian Damian's life philosophy
is honestly I just do what I feel like
and while everyone else looked up to
heroes he grew up wanting to be a
villain because it gave him a certain
thrill although his family was initially
quark list something happened and Damien
developed a flame based quirk which
allowed him to join the greatest gang
called the Black Rose Krim also left a
cool illustration of his villain on
Twitter
kaga me 360 wants to see a new
overarching antagonist or villain for a
saga the villain would have a quirk that
allows him to take over the body of any
one day choose and then use that
person's quark body swapping powers are
always interesting and lead to the
craziest plot twists so I would
definitely be down for something like
that and we have infinity King visor 277
who has a very cool idea he says that
deck whose dad is a villain who is
working to gather all the other villains
around the world to join sides with the
league of villains and he's doing all
this under the guise of being a
businessman going on a bunch of business
trips which is why he is so often away
in the story the name of his quark would
be God's gift and
allows him to give quirks to querulous
people deck whose dad loves his family
very much and he doesn't want them to
come into the hero versus villain
conflict so he decides to leave that
kook worklist so he wouldn't be able to
fight but at some point that Guzman
becomes suspicious of her husband so she
doesn't tell him when that who suddenly
develops his own work which of course we
know is one for all I think this is a
really cool idea because I really want
to know more about that whose dad and
there has to be some reason why he is
away so often if dec whose dad turned
out to be a villain that would be a huge
twist and it would open up so many
options with Deku having to face him
later on in the series so something
along those lines would definitely be
cool in my book over on Instagram Ian's
Kazakh wants to see a villain called gas
but he is not exactly a villain more so
vigilante who just does what he wants to
do regardless of what the law says the
name of the villains quirk would be rage
and the angrier the person becomes the
more strength and power they get and
they can even get to a point where they
lose control of their sanity and go
berserk the main enemy of gas would
actually be Eraserhead due to the fact
that gas sees Eraserhead
as an unjust hero that corrupts the
youth Ian sees the League of villains
potentially trying to recruit this
villain but he refuses and he is very
dangerous but also has the potential to
become one of the strongest heroes I
definitely like this idea of villain who
is not 100% a villain kind of like stain
so he functions outside the law he
doesn't let the law limit his actions
but he's not necessarily evil he's doing
what he believes is right I find
characters like that very interesting
also an Instagram of City and Jade
proposes a villain named Zeke a jazz
musician who works at a nightclub and
plays the trumpet and sax this jazz club
is a gathering spot for modern day
shinobi and spies and gathering
information and enforcing dark contracts
are just some of the things that Zeke
and his posse do Zeke's quirk is
manipulating sound waves to caress your
soul or shatter your bones
I assume that Zeke's quirk is activated
by his musical instruments and only on
clear notes does he have the most effect
and each note is a specific style of
attack
playing too loud for too long we'll have
negative physical consequences on the
you
this quirk I have to say extra bonus
points to obsidian jage for coming up
with a villain who is a jazz musician
and works at a jazz club that is just
awesome I want to see this as soon as
possible a bunch of badass jazz musician
villains going around and takin over the
underworld in the world of boku no hero
come on horikoshi let's make it happen
but that is all I have time for in this
video guys thank you so much for
participating if you want to take part
in next week's video be sure to follow
at anime uproar on Twitter and Instagram
I still want to see some more cool
suggestions for new boku no hero
villains so be sure to reply to those
threads on Twitter and Instagram with
your ideas if you enjoy these types of
videos and you want to keep seeing them
weekly be sure to leave a like to let me
know if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you could be
notified every time a new video is out
as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]